c'est comme un voleur tu te sens
regarder alors personne te regarde c'est
pas grave ce que tu fais là mais ça
tente pas de quelqu'un de voix pose des
questions c'est sûr qu'on se demande
tout le temps c'est quoi que je fais je
suis quelqu'un de surprend
quoi qu'ils vont dire un monsieur là
vous avez pas le droit de planter un
arbre
ce que vous faites illégal oui mais je
pense que il y a des choses pire que ça
dans la vie
[Musique]
les changements qui m'a dit
ça te cache sous peine
[Musique]
cette casse perdait
si maintenant il coupait là c'est pas
grave je serais pas fâché mais non il
vient te chercher jusque dans le fond ça
vient me chercher
donc là c'est ma pépinière ici moi ma
pépinière elle a deux volets elle a le
volet planta clandestin puis le volet
Van Damme donc quiconque peut m'appeler
dire ben je veux des arbres moi en
contrepartie c'est que les arbres que je
vende sève à financer ce que je plante
clandestinement
je suis peut-être rendu environ 300
arbres à peu près que j'ai planté sur la
terre publique je me suis mis un défi de
50 heures par année
le changement clinique c'est un maquette
beaucoup c'est pas vrai que je vais
regarder mes enfants en face en leur
disant j'ai rien fait moi je vais être
capable dans 10-20 ans dire mes enfants
mais j'ai fait ce que je pouvais faire
puis ce que je sais faire le mieux cette
plante est déjà
[Musique]
c'est quoi
c'est souvent le moment le plus
difficile c'est quoi choisir
comme choisir c'est ces petits bébés
qu'on a élevé tiens toi je t'emmène
mais des fous là je réfléchis pendant
des semaines à ce que je vais planter ou
ça à quel endroit puis j'en ai jamais
planté des comme ça c'est un chêne
Philippe solidaire c'est la famille des
chênes rouges ça c'est unique là c'est
un art extraordinaire un rouge bordeaux
comme ça
Super Bowl
[Musique]
là on va aller se diriger vers l'hôpital
je sais que ça dérangera pas là où je
vais en mettre parce que il faut tout le
temps réussir à deviner se situe un
endroit qui aura une construction il y a
tu des motoneiges qui passent à l'hiver
il y a tout l'aspect déneigement aussi
s'il y a pas d'arbre pour quelle raison
c'est beaux distincts il faut pas que ça
devienne n'importe quoi OK
[Musique]
ils vont passer par là
ils vont être contents de le voir
[Musique]
du monde qui quand on va à l'hôpital en
général à part quand c'est des
naissances ces années une bonne nouvelle
tu regardes ici c'est tellement immense
comme territoire
est bonne ça rentre comme dans du beurre
ce n'est quasiment gênant
pourquoi entretenir des grands terrains
alors qu'on sait que la solution s'est
planter des milliards d'arbres à
l'échelle de la planète pour atténuer le
changement climatique tandis que des
arbres et ça refuse pour animaux il va
nourrir tout un écosystème c'est juste
inutile de laisser un endroit pas
d'arbre
c'est pas trouvable un arbre de même
parce que les villes achètent des arbres
en gros format eux ils veulent des gros
arbres il y a pas cher puis en grosses
quantité ça c'est un arbre de collection
c'est ça aussi la biodiversité c'est de
mettre toutes sortes
on va aller dans un coin qu'on est déjà
planté par le passé avec des amis
puis là on voit on éclaire justement un
arbre qui a 4 ans
ça c'est ma récompense quand je vois que
ça fonctionne mais c'est sûr qu'il faut
très beau il y a de la misère
un arbre c'est un peu comme un
adolescent
puis finalement
ça se passe très bien les adultes faut
être patient
mais tant qu'il y a de la vie il y a de
l'espoir
il est là il est en face
donc l'idée là c'est qu'on va planter
deux chaînes blancs proches comme ça
mais plus tard ils vont pouvoir spoliser
entre eux
c'est planter sur les terres publiques
parce que ça appartient à tout le monde
un lieu privé là ça fonctionne tant que
la personne veut garder ses arbres si le
monde meurt si le monde nous vendent
tandis que sur une terre publique ben ça
appartient à tout le monde il y a
personne qui pourra interdire la
population d'en profiter
[Musique]
lui je l'ai planté il y a trois ans
quand je vois cet art bloque c'est quand
même la fierté de dis-donc si moi je
n'avais pas planté il serait Pollo il y
a aucune possibilité 0 puis une barre
qui a un noyé noir pousse ici la ville
n'aura jamais de noyer noire donc là
j'ai vraiment fait quelque chose ici
même là
[Musique]
quand on plante un arbre ça va quand
même vite c'est un petit 10 minutes
qu'on prend dans notre vie puis qu'on
dit
10 minutes
il donne ça pour 150 ans c'est pas mal
c'est comme un beau rendement
en capitalise
ça
y est